Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We are recording a session on a topic that we're constantly researching here. So this is going to be on how to stimulate apoptosis with cancer patients through a specific pathway and some things that may block apoptosis in cancer patients. So we'll all explain that.
You can find some of this information in my books available on our website. If you haven't done that, all this information that we're talking about in this presentation is going to be in the new cancer genes book.
So let's jump into this topic is going to be a role of superoxide iodine in cancer. Superoxide iodine is considered a free radical that is made in your body and in as a intermediate metamolite that is supposed to be then gotten rid of in your body and we'll talk about that.
It can form a peroxidite rate in the presence of uncoupled nitric oxide. We'll talk about that a little bit. It can be a partaker in hydroxyl free radical formation and can be just a man guy that can cause cancer in different ways and cause cell damage in other ways and cause all sorts of problems. So let's jump right into that.
Don't memorize this, but a few things I want to talk about this, this FAS pathway is what we're going to be talking about and where superoxide iodine really blocks this pathway, the FAS pathway. So this is actually the membrane of the cell.
So all your cells have a membrane around it and in the membrane are these embedded enzyme proteins that act as receptor sites.
So receptors, you could think of them as a lock and a key mechanism maybe that turn on different things inside the cell in the FAS receptor pathway turns on the cap space pathway, which is the apoptotic pathway, which is one of your major apoptotic pathways.
So when we talk about cancer patients, we cancer cells are not going through apoptosis. So apoptosis is normal program cell death, it's called normal because it's supposed to take place in all cells, all cells do not live forever.
They go through this cell death process of basically recycling intracellular material, reutilize it that's a normal death of a cell, well, it is a process and it's a pathway because it doesn't just die like you think it's all these chemical pathways that test take place that is actually much more intricate than what's seen on this diagram, this is an abbreviated diagram.
And there's things that could get inside the cells and block this, one of those things is super oxide ion.
So super oxide ion, one of the damaging things of the super oxide ion is that it get in the cell and it can block this pathway so it blocks apoptosis and can be that a precursor to cancer.
And it can hinder chemotherapy's activity on a cell, it can hinder all sorts of alternative therapies trying to stimulate apoptosis, you have this free radical super oxide ion that's actually blocking everything you're trying to do and kill cancer cells in a patient.
So understand the FAS pathway stimulates apoptosis super oxide ion blocks the FAS pathway so it's blocking apoptosis, hindered cell death in a cancer patient.
So let's talk, we need to find out where the heck is this super oxide ion coming from and how could we intervene and block this makes sense to me.
So thanks to Dr. Ben Lynch with this chart that he created for looking at your genetics and looking at your different metabolic pathways.
So here's the super oxide ion, we talk about this in a lot of my genetic videos because we see defects on this, this genetic pathway quite frequently with cancer patients.
And now we're starting to learn what that actually does to a person in that metabolic process.
So SOD stands for super oxide dispute case.
This is the gene, there's multiple genes in this family.
It's purpose is to make super oxide dispute case, aptly named, right?
So the SOD gene makes super oxide dispute case, what does that do?
Well it grabs onto super oxide that's in the cell and it gets rid of it, it turns it into hydrogen peroxide.
Then with the help of glutathione and cantalase, it turns it into water and you pee it out into the toilet.
So your body has a way to get rid of super oxide.
So it doesn't cause issues like this and block the fast pathway which blocks a poptosis.
We don't want that to take place, right?
So we want to make sure we have plenty of super oxide dispute case to grab onto this.
Well it even gets worse and we're going to put another video together on what super oxide this super oxide ion is left alone.
It can bind to uncoupled nitric oxide in form peroxide nitrate, but that's another lecture.
So we need to look at excess super oxide ions in cancer patients.
So again in summary, super oxide ion will through the process of of combining with super oxide dispute case made by the super oxide dispute case genes.
Form hydrogen peroxide and then with cantalase and glutathione forms water and oxygen, you get rid of it.
That's the goal. It's when this isn't taking place right here.
This isn't taking place right here that we get excess super oxide ion and excess super oxide ion can block a poptosis.
Okay, so it's not really that difficult, but this is what's taking place. So we got to figure out what's going on there.
So how do we look at this in a patient? Can we measure super oxide ion in the cell? No, we can't.
Can we look at a person's genetics to see if maybe they're producing with their leaving excess super oxide in the cell and not getting rid of it.
Yes, so the first gene you look at is the super oxide dispute case gene.
So again, this is the gene we're looking at. The super oxide dispute case gene. That's the first one we need to look at.
So that's the closest upstream from super oxide. It's whole purpose is to grab onto it and get rid of it out of the cell.
So these are the genes that we're looking at.
And remember when we look at genes, it's either going to be a plague like on this nerve two gene right here.
That's a plague that we do that person has no defect.
You know that are they're going to have inherited it a Leo a defective a Leo a variant from either their mother or their father.
Just one of them would be a one. If they inherited a Leo from their mother and their father, they will have a two like this gene and this gene right here.
So we don't want to have defects on any of these genes defects on these genes will not you won't hinder its ability to function.
So this person right here as defects on all their SOD genes here. So this function is going to be decreased.
There's other things that could decrease this function too.
We're just talking about from a genetic perspective. If the person has a lot of SOD gene defects, they're going to have excess SOD super oxide, which can be a cause of cancer.
And or a piece of the inability for a cancer cell to die. Right.
So we need that pathway. We need this pathway functioning. If we're going to kill cancer cells, this can inherently be blockied it.
So we want to look at from a genetic perspective. Is there anything that is hindered the body to get rid of super oxen ion.
We also got to look at catalyse and the whole glutathione pathway. And this is just a few of the glutathione genes that we're looking at here.
Because we want to look at, you know, are we producing enough of this is this backed up to we have excess proxy diet rate or excess hydrogen peroxide that's backing up this whole pathway.
So if there's issues with glutathione, if there's issues with catalyse, if there's issues with how glutathione is made through the nerve to pathway. That's why I put those genes on there too.
Then we're going to have that whole system backed up and we could have excess super oxide and that's going to be the big hindrance for of cancer apoptosis taking place. Does that make sense?
So looking at those genes is going to be key and then we can support those pathways. Maybe we want to give SOD in this case. Maybe we want to give some catalyse. Maybe we'd support the glutathione pathway or the nerve to pathway.
Here's just some products that I may use, but your practitioner may use different products.
Curcumid is very important in helping those pathways. Here's a nerve to accelerator to support glutathione production anti-inflammatories and antioxidants help blocks that super oxide isn't oxidant, by the way.
Here's a bunch of data that where I got this information from, so you could look it up yourself if you don't believe me.
Again, look at my books and joy our website and enjoy other videos if this was helpful to you. Thank you much. Bye bye.